Speaker 1: David.
How can Democrats better appeal to rural voters?
So I don't know if this will be seen as controversial
by people in my audience, but a lot of Democratic
rhetoric on gun control is completely counterproductive.
I am probably right there with 95 percent
of the policy that many Democratic lawmakers
want on gun safety.
But every time that Democrats campaign on
gun control, no one many sound very uninformed,
very, very uninformed words like do they do
they even understand how guns work?
And that's a real problem for a huge part
of this country, including rural folks who
remember rural folks.
Relationship to guns is very different than
that of people who live in cities and suburbs
and other places.
Number two, I think that the focus needs to
better emphasize economic issues in a way
that relates to working class may be better
than sort of like tech millennials.
And I think that sometimes the economic rhetoric
of Democrats works pretty well for young people
and people working in white collar jobs, but
who are just not paid that well or with a
lot of student debt, but often is not rhetoric
and language that's well tuned to more rural
folks.
And this includes farmers.
This includes factory workers.
And, you know, just every once in a while
talking about unions, there's lots of rural
folks who have.
One local employer where you drive 40 miles
to a factory where we might think being on
the left, they should love to hear about how
we support unionization, look at what happened
in Alabama with Amazon, where they voted against
unionizing.
Now, of course, there was a huge propaganda
war and it's a much more complicated thing.
But having spoken to people who work in factories
in the Midwest and in other places, just talking
about unions is not going to do it for Democrats.
So I think that it's sort of a three pronged
approach.
I think the rhetoric around gun control around
elections has to be either dropped or fixed.
It doesn't mean you stop working on the issues.
It just means you stop campaigning so aggressively
on that because it turns a lot of those rural
folks off.
Number two, you figure out how to better talk
to farmers and agricultural employers and
workers.
And number three, you tweak the economic message
to not be so union heavy, but more about understanding
the plight of a lot of these economically
ravaged areas where whether the one employer
is unionized or not and I support the unionization,
that's not a path to fixing or dealing with
the way that the area has been ravaged.
Big picture overwhelmingly by the Republicans
sort of supply side policies that came out
of the 1980s.
Those would be my three kind of bits of advice
for Democrats to better appeal to rural voters.
And the truth is that appealing to rural voters
in California versus Mississippi are certainly
two different things.
And and the Midwest as a third one.
Those are my initial thoughts.
Let me know what you think.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
joint
Unidentified: Kim Dotcom that.